faire le point avec la psychiatre marié
ève coton bonsoir marie-eve
lancement julie vont écouter la question
allait soulever par le réalisateur ici
en comment faire pour aider une personne
qui s'est isolé comme ça qu'ils refusent
d'avoir de l'aide d'abord des comme ça
dans votre pratique qu'est ce que vous
en avez déjà vu
c'est à dire que des dépressions aussi
sévère que ça où les gens ne sortent
plus de chez eux sont complètement
inactives complètement coupé du monde
oui j'en ai vu c'est quand même une
condition à ses cours entre la
dépression majeure ce que j'ai trouvé
exceptionnel
inhabituelle dans le reportage pour de
monsieur où ce jeune monsieur thériault
c'est la durée que ça a pris un vent qui
accepte de rencontrer soignants
psychiatre saprissa semble avoir pris
six ans d'après ce qu'on comprend donc
sans habituellement les gens dépressifs
sont très souffrant de leur condition
donc les proches
souvent les encourage à consulter ils
peuvent être et 5 mai que ça prenne six
ans avant d'aller vers les soins se
soucier exceptionnel je n'ai jamais vu
ce qu'obama pratique comment une
dépression peut paralyser une personne à
ce point de la rendre complètement
recluse oui il ya eu plusieurs façons de
ne pas dans les symptômes de la
dépression il ya une perte complète de
d'intérêt de plaisir de motivation et
d'initiatives donc les moindres tâche
des choses très simples comme aller
prendre une marche aller faire
l'épicerie ça peut paraître comme une
montagne pour les gens même sortir de
leurs gongs leur divan ça peut paraître
comme une montagne l'autre élément c'est
qu'une perte très forte estime
personnelle qui peut aller jusqu'à la
honte de soi et les gens ne veulent pas
exposer sa aux autres qu'ils sont
honteux de ma maison ils se sentent
souvent coupables ils sont pas fiers
d'eux et donc dans le documentaire sur
monsieur thériault on entendait disait
je veux pas le pouvoir de gens je suis
capable de faire rire j'en serais pas
rire nous ma conjointe ni ma fille donc
on sentait cette dévalorisation le jeu
fait qu'il fallait coupe du monde
qu'elle ne nous appartient alizée à
l'intérieur la dernière simplement ce
qui aussi des symptômes anxieux parfois
qui accompagne aussi très fréquent et
donc les gens peuvent avoir aussi de
l'anxiété par exemple la cité sociale
être un type de rencontrer des gens ça
peut être aussi un facteur
est ce que je peux pas qu'on fasse
diagnostiquant nom puis on n'est pas là
dedans
mais le fait de monsieur thériault mais
ça peut être n'importe qui qui a connu
une carrière éblouissante il une superbe
carrière est-ce que ça rend les gens qui
ont eu des grands succès professionnel
comme ça peut-être plus fragiles quand
ils basculent parce que ils sont mis
tout le temps d attente tellement haut
de regarder on était tellement important
est-ce que ça compte ou pas
la personnalité de la personne
et sa vie va avoir un impact mais c'est
très personnalisé c'est très individuel
c'est soit que les gens parfois qui ont
été très performants dans l'est dans
leur vie que ce soit au niveau artistes
et dans la vie publique dans le sport et
cetera quand ils deviennent et on a une
problématique c'est ce qu'ils peuvent
avoir l'impression de tomber de haut
donc les pertes qu'ils vivent à ce
moment là sont importantes de passer de
effectivement de devait être le connu de
toute la province russe à une personne
qui reclus chez elle pendant six ans et
un énorme choc de fonctionnement si vous
voulez ou de statut donc en termes de
une parfois les gens qui se mettent
beaucoup de pression une perfectionniste
on parle des gens qui veulent avoir
l'approbation des autres ça peut être
une pression qui à la longue peut être
un facteur de risque également son sens
une certaine détresse chez les proches
aidants finalement se lancer des gens
qui font tout pour essayer de les
dessiner un proche qui a eu une grande
dépression on sait à quel point c'est
difficile quand on a beau tirer pousser
convaincre flatté
des fois on dit voyons comment ça se
fait que ça marche pas comment ça se
fait j'arrive pas à la convaincre à
l'emea c'est finalement pour pour lui
donner envie d'en faire confiance et de
me suivre pour aller chercher de l'aide
si difficile pour les proches
et très difficile parce que en fait
c'est moins concret une maladie mentale
qu'une maladie physique c'est quand
quelqu'un sclérose en plaques équivalent
prix c'est quelque chose de très concret
le dysfonctionnement quand quelqu'un dit
non je le vois personne c'est plus
abstrait c'est comme plus difficile de
comprendre mais c'est quoi la barrière
qu'est ce qui t'a ambages sortir de chez
vous donc lire cette incompréhension là
et est aussi effectivement le fait que
parfois les gens ont l'impression de
dire si ce qu'est ce que les proches
vont souvent se mettre une pression de
dire ça doit être ma faute si j'arrive
pas à le convaincre ou que j'arrive pas
à lui à lui dire ce qu'il faudrait pour
le faire sourire ou pour le rendre
heureux alors que c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça donc souvent qu'on
rencontre les proches ou les pistes ya
il faut justement l'heure l'heure les
informer de leurs limites ou s'ils ne
peuvent pas prendre la souffrance de la
personne sur leurs épaules et la porter
à leur place
alors c'est très lourd tout ça on voit
quel point on voit qu'un aboutissement
dans les commentaires ça vaut vraiment
la peine de le regarder jusqu'au bout là
pour voir finalement quand même comment
on sort de tout ça
parce que ça aussi ça soulève toutes
sortes dangereux alors qu'il met presse
donc est allé chercher de l'aide on
n'est pas tout le monde suppose ex et
est de l'inde pour des problèmes de
santé mentale lui-même arrivé mixte un
problème de consommation mais ce qu'on
doit complètement exclure le problème de
santé mentale quand il ya un problème de
consommation marie-eve
non ça c'est possible parfois que les
gens consomment comme automédication
d'un trouble de santé mentale sous
jacent que ce soit un troubles anxieux
une dépression justement donc c'est pas
exclue il peut aussi avoir une
dépendance aux substances indépendante
sept centres augmente à l'autre donc les
deux sont possibles
et mais de toute façon le trop d'abus de
substances et
troublant soit qui va devoir qui va
devoir être adressés le son le plan
fiscal moi je trouve ça par contre assez
positif de voir des hommes des figures
publiques
masculine demander de l'aide parce que
les hommes consultent encore beaucoup
moins en santé mentale que les femmes et
c'est une des raisons qui expliquent
pour lesquels ils se suicident plus
alors de commencer à voir des figures
masculines forte connu se tourner vers
les services en disant ça peut arriver à
tout le monde personne n'est infaillible
ça m'est arrivé je pense qu'au niveau de
l'impact sur la population ça peut être
positif alors finalement c'est ça parce
que c'est un symbole
qui représente quelque chose justement
sorte de super héros du jeu hockey qui a
connu ces mamans ses blessures on le
sait mais d'admettre publiquement comme
ceux de faire cet aveu alors que
finalement le côté l'exemple qu'on donne
là bas
absolument et la crise c'est une
représentation de la masculinité
traditionnel injustement ougoulava ce
titre canale est encore beaucoup mises
de l'avant et c'est justement ces
valeurs masculines traditionnels ou
l'autonomie c'est à dire l'idée qu'un
homme sa règle ses problèmes seul ça
peut pas avoir besoin d'être dan
extérieures qui n'ont pas remis en
question son identité masculine c'est ce
genre de valeur le soufflet
traditionnels qui sont un frein ou fait
d'aller chercher de l'aide alors voilà
donc une brise un tabou une certaine
façon un meriem et ont toujours un
plaisir de vous recevoir en entrevue
merci pour vos lumières aujourd'hui je
signale d'ailleurs à noter le spectateur
on vient de mettre en ondes
100 des coûts d'entrée de ce les gens
jamais on avait besoin ou si vous avez
un proche vous pensez qu'il est mal pris
vous savez pas quoi faire vous savez pas
comment l'aider vous pouvez appeler à
ces lignes d'entrée à montréal 5 1 4 de
7 8 21 30 merci encore à docteur quand